ah she nasty but I low-key like that so
I'm in the middle I'm in the middle is
he nasty though yo what's up this is
drewski this is red flags and we about
to get into it your date only sends
voice memos
that's a red flag I'm tired of people
doing that man like you talk to some of
these celebrities and they don't even
text anymore it's all like voice memos
through everything it's like come on man
let's get it together dude I want to
talk but I'm not trying to be on the
phone right your date doesn't like
wearing sandals oh man get out of here
what are you doing Mama it's all aware
baby your day pulls out a mini flosser
at dinner oh I love that because more
people need to floss your breath smells
like
I preach that a lot you know people
don't know your gums got to stay healthy
for your breath to smell good so like I
said your breath smells like
get some flaws your Tate orders
everything with the side of ketchup ah
she nasty but I low-key like that so I'm
in the middle I'm in the middle see
nasty though you nasty but I like that I
like that your date says their ex is
crazy
that's actually a green one Michael a
lot and it's a reason why the brothers
out there that got them crazy ones or
then dealt with the you know y'all know
what that lead to
your date calls you baby after the first
date
we can't come on now that's no I call
you mama baby that's yeah too soon your
day tries to take a selfie with you
right away well in the predicament I met
yeah not happening your date has vastly
different music taste than you oh I kind
of like that though I I like different
genres of music you know I listen to a
lot of country your date tries food off
of your plate
torn man I hate stuff like that man come
on you know why don't you get what I got
if you wanted it you should have ordered
it right your date has never watched one
of your videos oh that's kind of that's
kind of you know because I mean if she
on a date with me that means she just
into me she looking at the looks I like
to look at myself as a sex symbol not
only my talent could turn you on baby
[Music]
your date calls you baby oh man I call
you Mama I call you Mama
baby that's not too soon your day keeps
pulling out her phone during dinner
fellas she's going home with somebody
else you're paying for the date you're
preguning with her she's going home with
him
your date's favorite movie genre is
horror films horror films weird you're a
weirdo thanks ciao
thanks for playing red flags with
drewski go get your tickets at for
lifersworld.com to come see me at the
club Woulda Shoulda tour why wouldn't
you do it